on dirait une barque à la dérive
mais en regardant de plus près on
distingue des fleurs de campagne ou sur
une feuille de châtaignier nils udo
trompe l'oeil du public l'obligeant à
s'arrêter à contempler ce nom c'est
vraiment une poésie de la nature qui se
réalise à travers ça on serait une
patience toujours dans ce travail là
qu'il a mis dans mes mains de temps à
chaque fois pour réaliser une
photographie là dedans évidemment on
doit rentrer dedans on doit se laisser
faire pour entrer dans l'exposition
l'artiste allemand est un pionnier du
land art le mouvement de l'art dans la
nature avec ses photographies comme ses
peintures il représente une botanique
comme steam et personnel on a
l'impression dans l'exposition de
peinture de ventre et comme nous sommes
dans une forêt dense et à travers les
sous bois on voit petit à petit notre
regard s'accoutumer et là on distingue
quelques formes des tendons transparent
des lumières qui miroite et bleu des
eaux
émile sud restitue la nature pourrait
par elle-même avec émotion et communion
un instant suspendu
[Musique]
où